80.000 habitantes de los cuales 23 mil
son árabes y una presencia policial
reforzada la ciudad objetivo de un
ataque de misil desde gaza que dejó dos
muertos es del escenario de
enfrentamientos violentos entre judíos y
árabes una violencia que llevó al primer
ministro benjamin netanyahu a declarar
el estado de urgencia
atacan a los ciudadanos a los policías
queman casas coches sinagogas es
evidente que no podemos aceptarlo ningún
país lo haría definitivamente nosotros
no hace días que la minoría árabe
israelí algunos de los cuales prefieren
denominarse palestinos nativos expresan
su cólera el lunes una manifestación
estalló tras la muerte de un
manifestante árabe a manos de un judío
israelí la situación terminó en
enfrentamientos vehículos y comercios
terminaron quemados igual que sinagogas
y un cementerio musulmán en otras
ciudades llamadas mixtas también
estallaron enfrentamientos como en un
mal fama cerca de haifa o en acre la
policía de israel asegura haber detenido
decenas de personas y habla de eventos
sin precedentes
los árabes israelíes o palestinos
nativos son descendientes de los
palestinos que se quedaron en sus
tierras tras la fundación de israel en
1948 representan cerca de un 20% de la
población pero dicen sentirse tratados
como ciudadanos de segunda